ils sont à l'entrée bon bah je pense à
mettre vos téléphones sur le court ou
encore dans les vestiaires
les bénévoles sont partout retraité
habitué lycéens ou encore étudiant
pendant une semaine ils vont vivre au
rythme intense de l'open d'orléans
sous la houlette d'une colle et lionel
je vous rassure je vais mettre mes
rollers et je vais revenir sinon tout va
bien les 9 heures nycole sur le pont
elle arpente les couloirs du palais des
sports pour régler les derniers détails
avant le grand briefing de 10 heures
mais du coup ils rentraient parce que
pour le rouge
voilà alors que l'agent de sécurité lui
va dire vous n'avez pas votre badge vous
ne rentrez pas pour moi des bénévoles
c'est très important
d'où l'intérêt du briefing de les
écouter leurs doléances leurs problèmes
rencontrés et puis par et à leurs petits
soucis c'est pas grand chose mais pour
eux c'est très important
toute la semaine nicole et lionel vont
sillonner le palais des sports de long
en large et de haut en bas le plus
rapide des deux c'est lionel le
responsable des bénévoles
il lui arrive parfois de parcourir plus
de 13 kilomètres dans la journée
trèves à l'appui mon engin me compte le
nombre de pas le nombre des tâches que
je fais tous les jours et dans le palais
la moyenne bas la moyenne vous voyez
c'est ses 12 13 km 47 étages et 17000
pas voilà le travail de lionel ne se
résume pas qu'à la semaine de l'open on
a les habitués à peu près plus de la
moitié des gens qui reviennent d'une
année sur l'autre donc très souvent une
demande d'être au même poste que l'année
passée et puis ensuite il faut aller
baba fois c'est ça c'est les réseaux
sociaux c'est pas moi qui m'en occupe
mais essayer de recruter de nouveaux
bénévoles que c'est pas facile
je rappelle que bénévole s'est passé une
semaine sans être payés avec comme seule
compensation de pouvoir voir les matchs
et puis d'être dans une équipe sympa
robbie est en bac pro relation client
c'est sa première expérience
professionnelle
mon vrai défi c'est de m'occuper des
joueurs qui vont à un besoin que je suis
présent pour eux c'est un repère le
frigo prendre leurs serviettes et donne
à l'accueil pour qu'ils quittent les
laver et après la poursuite donc avant
que j'arrive yale jeu c'est moi qui fais
la lumière et après je reviens à voir
les genres c'est très bien avec l'ibsr
des gens à part si près des joueurs donc
je peux des voix et la poursuite bat un
peu de pression parce que va faire la
lumière tout votre regard oui sinon
j'aime bien les soutiens
dimanche à la fin du tournoi les 200
bénévoles seront tous bien fatigués mais
ils auront eu la satisfaction d'avoir
contribué au bon déroulement de l'open
d'orléans
l'un des meilleurs tournois challengers
au monde